welcome everyone to zagreb it is time to
crown our winner magnus carlson won the
tournament commanding lead throughout
the event but to say a few words first
we have the executive director of the
grand chess tour michael horkowski
thank you alejandra we just concluded
another exciting tournament third lag of
the grand chess tour it was one of the
most exciting tournaments of this year
and first of all i would like to thank
our sponsors super united and certainly
great performance by the world champion
magnus carlson
and now i pass
a microphone to president
of the executive committee of the super
united our sponsors marion marusic
thank you
first of all welcome to zagreb uh
congratulations mr magnus i'm happy to
have you here as a host hope to have you
next year again again congratulations
and enjoying croatia
magnus a blistering performance
yesterday you just went seven out of
nine and after that you seemed
completely uncatchable few words about
the event
yeah
i mean it started a bit
uh
i mean the second day was a bit tough
for me um
and the rapid in general was not so was
not so good but i think i was
lucky that nobody really had
like
a superb performance uh
for instance like maxim and alvarez had
great performances today but they
didn't do so well in the on the other
days
um
so um overall yeah the two last games
it's a it's a bit
um it's a pity to
uh to bow out in such a way but to be
honest i was uh really tired throughout
the day today so i was just trying to
get through it and
yeah once the
you know the tournament victory was
there uh you
you can't
care so much but
overall
great experience to be here i really
really like
the city
it's just a very good atmosphere here
and that's at the tournament as well
and hope to hope to be back
absolutely not a stranger to be holding
the trophy world champion magnus carlson
the winner here in the zagreb grand
chess tour guys let's go back to the
studio to close out our show this is all
we have from zagreb thank you very much
alejandro as once again we uh
congratulate
magnus carlson on his first place and
we're going to go
from
all the players what they earned in
terms of
reward money as well as grand chester
points and as we get set up for that i'd
like to say once again a great thanks to
the st louis chess club